[Musique]
bonsoir à lundi 29 juin bienvenue dans
cette édition spéciale sur tv 78
consacré au second tour des élections
municipales tout de suite les titres
verdict est livrée pour le scrutin dans
le département les yvelines où la
participation s'élève à 37,8 pour cent
en plein contexte épidémique
c'est en recul de trois points par
rapport au premier tour analyses et
réactions à suivre à l'issue de ce
second tour quatre nouveaux maires ont
été élus à saint quentin en yvelines
c'est le cas à vil prix les
clayes-sous-bois trappe
et puis à la verrière la surprise de ces
élections la ville passe à droite après
43 ans de gestion communiste en france
étaient les électeurs de 45 commune
yvelinoise en tout qui se déplacer aux
urnes ce dimanche parmi lesquels
notamment mantes-la-ville et rambouillet
tour d'horizon des principaux résultats
dans le département c'est l'un des
enseignements de cette soirée électorale
en pleine crise sanitaire le chiffre de
l'abstention est élevé voire très élevé
au niveau national moins d'un français
sur deux a voté une abstention estime à
50 9% bonsoir mélanie poker bon ça de la
rédaction de tv 78 qu'on est il dans les
yvelines dans les yvelines c'est plus de
62 % d'abstention dans le département à
les électeurs se sont encore moins
déplacés qu'au niveau national
on aurait pu peut-être jusqu'au bout
espérer un rebond mais enfin
manifestement je pense que le fait que
plus de trois mois est séparé le le
second tour du premier à vraiment jouer
un rôle a vraiment une influence tout à
fait fondamental il y avait sans doute
encore quelques petites inquiétudes
voire grandes inquiétudes chez certains
citoyens au sujet de la pandémie mais je
crois que là enfin cesser c'est ce qui
s'appelle de ce point de vue les deux
catastrophes
la participation est en baisse constante
depuis 1983 elle elle était à 80 % 1
remis la veille 1 80 point la
participation aux municipales donc 20 %
d'abstention 36 % d'abstention en 2014
au plan national donc les chiffres
actuels c'est c'est vraiment un désastre
et la participation mais la nier est
inégale selon les communes du
département et mais on peut même dire
que
est un véritable grand écart 45 communes
appelé les électeurs à revenir dans les
bureaux de vote dimanche
et c'est à senlis qu'on a le plus voté
l'abstention de monde qu'à 19 76% dans
cette commune avec 415 inscrits sur les
listes du côté de l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines c'est à la
verrière qu'il y a eu le plus de
bulletins de vote dans les urnes
51 08 % des 3146 inscrits ont voté et
c'est d'ailleurs dans une commune de
saint quentin en yvelines conte allemand
a rassemblé oui est ce que pour les
électeurs le premier tour semble et
pillés mais à guyancourt plus de 70% des
votants ont choisi de ne pas se déplacer
un chiffre bien au dessus de la moyenne
yvelinoise et même de la moyenne
nationale mais de manière générale ce
second tour n'a pas mobilisé les foules
et cette dernière commune
saint-quentinoise qui devaient choisir
leurs maires ont dépassé les 50%
d'abstention va le voir à l'écran
alors j'ai déjà dû pour la verrière mais
le taux est à 51% voisins-le-bretonneux
ses 55% villepreux 56 les
clayes-sous-bois 59 trappe 61 et donc
guyancourt plus de 70%
mais pour certaines communes c'est le
contraire l'abstention a quand même
baissé lors de ce second tour
en vidant toujours pour saint quentin en
yvelines c'est le cas de trois communes
la verrière trappe et les pieds sous
voie même si cette dernière tout est
relatif puisque le taux d'abstention des
deux tours tourne autour des 50 9%
et c'est à nouveau à guyancourt que
l'écart est le plus important plus de
huit points d'augmentation
merci mélanie pour ces précisions à léon
début de ce tour d'horizon des résultats
du second tour avec la surprise de ce
scrutin à saint-quentin-en-yvelines la
commune de la verrière bascule à droite
une perte historique pour la gauche dans
ce bastion communiste depuis 1977 et
nicolas dainville a remporté ce second
tour avec plus de 47% des voix elle
devance en la maire sortante nelly du
tuf le récit de nicolas landry
c'est un scrutin historique pour la
commune de la verrière un basculement à
droite pour cette ville communiste
depuis 1977
le candidat divers droite nicolas
dainville remporte ces élections
municipales 2020 avec 47 52 % des
suffrages
une victoire de justesse avec 58 voix
d'avancé sur nelly duthu grande joie une
grande responsabilité
un grand honneur on a envie avec
l'équipe de faire des belles choses pour
cette ville de la verrière de lui à
impulser une nouvelle dynamique et et
c'est très important qu'on se mette au
travail dès demain pour agir sur
l'emploi sur l'éducation sur la sécurité
sur le cadre de vie dans cette
triangulaire du second tour la gauche
partait divisée d'un côté la maire
sortante communiste nelly duthu élu en
2007 suite à la démission d'alain ajaj
de l'autre jean yves blé son premier
adjoint qui en 2019 créer un groupe au
sein de la majorité avec plusieurs élus
sur fond de désaccords unis dans ce
scrutin la gauche aurait pu l'emporter
dommage peut être qu'ils aient division
à gauche et qui pense que si on
additionne le au premier tour les les
voix de monsieur blé et les miennes on
passe au premier tour ok un petit peu
compliqué cette division mais bon voilà
je suis pas sûr que les mesures que vont
prendre le ch est dingue il soit dans
l'intérêt des derniers rois donc à
chaque fois que les interactions menacer
mais c'est david va nous trouver sur la
sur sa route
on a plus d'une fois essayé de tendre la
main madame du tout madame ne l'a jamais
rendu finalement je crois que la rupture
est elle s'opère au départ de monsieur
hajjaj finalement on a constitué une
équipe là prêts à être à l'écouté de
monsieur dainville et attendre
lui qui nous écoutent également le
conseil municipal d'installation de la
verrière aura lieu ce samedi 4 juillet à
10 heures au centre culturel du scarabée
elle la verrière longtemps fief
communiste désormais avec un maire de
droite de quoi réjouir le président du
conseil départemental pierre bédier
écoutez la réaction de celui qui est
également président de la fédération les
républicains des yvelines il voit là
même à la berri était le favori des
pronostics on a opéré le benjamin des
maires des villes donc dans ces jolis
cru je me satisfait de voir que la
majorité départementale et les
conseillers départementaux à l'exception
notable de la conseillère départementale
de maisons laffitte
mais qui est allé au combat contre le
maire de nant la cité contre la vie
contre mon avis c'est à dire dont elle
est conseillère départementale mais en
l'espèce c'était contre l'avis du
conseil départemental 1 et notre vie
sont sortis plutôt renforcée de ce
scrutin il se sent suis heureux heureux
tout renault sur trois pour le
département et pour l'institution
départementale
pas de surprise ou presque en revanche
attrape les trois candidats qualifiés
pour le second tour se sont classés dans
le même ordre d'arrivée que le 15 mars
dernier la liste de l'ex adjoint ali
rabais l'emportent devant celle de manas
roues et du maire sortant guy malandain
qui cède donc son fauteuil après 19 ans
demande à trappes aura bientôt un
nouveau maire dans ce second tour où
c'était une triangulaire qui était
proposé aux électeurs la liste conduite
par ralliera verts remporte le scrutin
est la gauche unie pour que tu rappes
respire soutenu par génération europe
ecologie les verts le parti communiste
et tout récemment le parti socialiste
totalise 40,4 % des votes
un grand sentiment de fierté parce que
les trappistes à plus de 40 % ont choisi
de porter la liste de la gauche unie
pour que tu vas prescrire
et également un sentiment de
responsabilité parce que je suis élu
dans un contexte particulier celui de la
crise du corona virus qui frappe encore
notre pays et il y a besoin ici plus
qu'ailleurs de solidarité de services
publics d'engagement de la part des
fonctionnaires de la part des
associations de la ville et nous
disposons ici de grande énergie de
grandes forces vives ma responsabilité
sera de les mobiliser
l'ancien adjoint et membre de la
majorité s'était présenté face à guy
malandain maire sortant en lice pour un
quatrième mandat
soutenu par la république en marche et
lâché entre les deux tours par le parti
socialiste est la tête de liste de pour
trappe la gauche qui agit se classe en
troisième position avec un score de 22
4%
élu en 2001 guy malandain passe donc la
main après dix neuf ans à la tête de la
municipalité et n'a pas décidé encore
s'il siégera dans l'opposition je garde
le souvenir d'avoir fait d'avoir fait au
mieux
rien n'est parfait il ya toujours des
choses à faire
je ne me vois pas passer le bâton du
relais de la course à pied comme ça à
quelqu'un qui que j'ai invité avec son
copain amont là que j'ai invité à venir
dans l'équipe pour terminer par une
une trahison tout simplement distancée
de dix points au premier tour othman
nasro lui arrive à la deuxième place
avec 37,18 % des suffrages mais avec un
écart qui s'est resserré cent soixante
et une voie entre sa liste engagement
trappe citoyens et celle d'ali rabais en
duo avec mustapha larbaoui pour le
scrutin il envisage de déposer un
recours suite aux résultats de ce second
tour
nous avons fait nous où deux chemins
nous devions faire pour proposer autre
api une autre alternative que l'élection
de monsieur rabais parce que je
considère que ce serait totalement
catastrophique pour trappe
je le dis j'en parle au conditionnel
puisque on regarde des conditions dans
lesquelles s'est déroulé ce scrutin au
regard des attaques personnelles des
méthodes qui ont été employés nous
envisageons de déposer un recours
à noter que la participation est en
hausse à trappes 38,25 % soit 4 points
en plus par rapport au premier tour
conseils d'installation prévue ce
vendredi 3 juillet à 19 heures en mairie
et ce sont quatre communes en tout à
saint quentin en yvelines où les
électeurs ont fait le choix du
changement à l'issue de ce second tour à
la verrière et trappes donc mais aussi
aux clayes sous bois et à villepreux le
tour d'horizon avec au rayon dans
quelques jours ces quatre communes de
saint quentin en yvelines verront à leur
tête un nouveau maire pour les six
prochaines années aux clayes-sous-bois
philippe guillen arrive en tête soutenue
au second tour par la maire sortante
véronique côté millard qui ne se
représentait pas il obtient 41,82 % des
suffrages
je souhaite remercier tous les clés
siens qui sont venus voter aujourd'hui
malgré des conditions pas toujours très
simple pour remercier tous les chrétiens
etc les siens qui ont porté leurs voix
sur mon nom les sur ma liste est aussi
bien entendu remercier
toute mon équipe qui depuis un an
travail sur le sur le terrain pour
essayer de monter un projet apprécié par
là par la population les listes menées
par le candidat divers gauche nicolas
hué la candidat divers centres
anne-claire frémont arrivent
respectivement en deuxième et troisième
positions c'est une déception
nous étions bien placés et
éventuellement pour passer en tête au
soir du premier tour
les conditions ont fait que
malheureusement certains certaine union
où certains ralliements n'ont pas pu se
se produire je pensais qu'une campagne
bienveillante et un programme un
programme constructif pour tous les clés
siens allaient suffire et bien non je me
rends compte qu'il faut faire une
campagne délétère ordurières pour gagner
at il pris le candidat jean baptiste à
monica arrivé en tête du scrutin et
applaudi par son équipe à l'annoncé des
résultats
il emporte de 30 points devant la
seconde liste
ce résultat de 55% 6 g selon jean croit
les derniers chiffres vient à la fois
concrétisé tous nos efforts de cette
campagne et la dynamique qu'on
commençait à sentir depuis quelques
semaines maintenant sur le terrain on
est en tête sur l'ensemble de bde bureau
donc par rapport au premier tour là
aussi c'est c'est une victoire une
progression on avait un seul bureau je
crois on n'était pas en tête au premier
tour donc là deux des trente est sûre
surtout les bureaux évidemment c'est ça
nous rend encore plus heureux on va dire
la liste agir tous pour villes pro issu
de la fusion entre valérie bain et
sylvie ce vent monte elle arrive en
deuxième position celle du maire sortant
stéphane denis rambaud qui n'était pas
présent lors de la soirée du second tour
arrive troisième on a quand même réussi
quelques succès sur cette campagne
puisque mon mal le projet immobilier en
question est en stand by pour l'instant
donc ça c'était si on n'avait pas fait
tous ces travaux ce ne serait jamais
arrivé
55 % c'est un score qui est excellent
avec trois listes et souhaite évidemment
beaucoup de beaucoup de courage et drake
it dont le mandat qui s'ouvre pour lui
du changement également pour les six
prochaines années à trappes
le candidat divers gauche à l'ira
et devance avec 40 40 % les listes du
candidat divers droite othman nasro et
du maire sortant guy malandain
enfin surprise à la verrière la maire
sortante communiste et nelly duthu est
devancé par le candidat divers droite
nicolas dainville il emporte avec un peu
plus de 47% des suffrages
le nouveau maire également du côté de
mantes la ville sammy damerdji a été élu
avec 55 points 85 % des voix avec la
candidature sans étiquette l'union pour
mantes la ville dans ce scrutin où deux
listes qualifier au second tour se sont
retirés il devance le maire sortant
cyril l'aude qui totalisent 40 4,15 %
des suffrages avec le rassemblement pour
mantes la ville est le rassemblement
national perd donc sa seule commune en
ile-de-france après le scrutin de 2014
et coûter ces réactions des candidats
celle d'abord du vainqueur sami damerdji
et puis du maire sortant battu cyril
note jeu très heureux parce que ses
listes aux citoyennes et rapportera 120
nationale
une liste qui a été aidé par aucun parti
sur lesquels aussi le report de voix est
mitigé des partis qui étaient de gauche
qui se sont retirés
quand c'est vraiment une liste qui
mérite cette victoire elle seule
j'espérais que l'éventuel report des
voix de gauche ne soit pas aussi
important malheureusement pour moi en
tout cas cela a été le cas et il n'y a
pas eu de surcroît de mobilisation des
abstentionnistes du premier tour et à
peine 2 % de plus de participation ce
qui est assez faible le duel tout le
monde le savait c'était la configuration
la moins favorable pour moi c'est de
désistement effectivement on s'en doute
provoqué cette 7e défaite dans une
triangulaire je pense que j'aurais eu
j'aurais mes chances pour pour
l'emporter
autre réaction à vous proposer
spécifiquement sur ce scrutin à
mantes-la-ville celle des responsables
politiques du département est la
déléguée du rassemblement national des
yvelines mathilde andrew est d'abord et
puis celle du président du département
des yvelines pierre bédier qui s'est
impliqué personnellement dans la
campagne en appelant à voter pour samy
damerdji une déception dans le sens où
on s'est rendu compte que tout le
système s'est pas fermé en préférant la
voyoucratie plutôt que la démocratie au
seul prétexte que le maire sortant était
rassemblement national et donc je te
souhaiter bonne chance aux grandes
villes ou à meyrin que la manière dont
s'est déroulé le scrutin au premier
comme au second tour avec des bureaux
terme entièrement tenus par des caïds
oui je trouve que la démocratie a perdu
de mairie aujourd'hui plus que le
rassemblement national le front national
avait gagné il ya six ans avant que la
ville passe carrick quadrangulaire et là
il ya une attitude particulièrement
républicaine des listes de gauche qui se
sont retirés et c'est vrai que moi j'ai
pas essayé de faire qu'ils vivent
d'alternative au front national
dès le premier jour de cette élection
légal mais illégitime et j'étais heureux
de voir c'était une citoyenne issus du
monde associatif qui je le sentais
viennent puisque cette ville et dans mon
canton était en train de te prendre le
dessus
créer la dynamique donc tout est bien
qui finit bien contre actions
collectives dans ces élections
municipales des élus sortants ont
également conforté leur position à saint
quentin en yvelines à l'issue du second
tour
trois maires ont été de nouveau désigné
à guyancourt voisins le bretonneux et
plaisir mathilde et demi pour les
détails dans la commune de guyancourt
c'est françois morton maire sortant et
tête de liste de décidons ensemble à
guyancourt qui est réélu avec 51 points
47% des voix
rodolphe baril est tête de liste
d'ensemble agissons pour guyancourt
arrive en deuxième position avec 32 0 4%
des voix et grégory pape tête de liste
de nouvel élan à guyancourt obtient
16,48 % des voix c'est une campagne qui
a été très longue
voilà très longue bien évidemment
puisque c'est inédit
trois mois entre les deux tours en ce
qui me concerne je suis devenu maire le
12 mai 2019
donc c'était effectivement une situation
aussi qu'ils étaient probablement
dangereuse
voilà pour pour la ville de guyancourt
et je suis absolument ravi d'avoir
établi dans quelques semaines avant les
élections détention régné dans la
commune de voisins-le-bretonneux entre
olivier afonso tête de liste du nid pour
voisins et alexandra rosetti maire
sortante
c'est finalement alexandra rosetti qui
remporte l'élection avec 53 10 % des
voix contre 30 points 91 pour olivier
afonso béatrice pire à tête de liste d'
avec vos voisins avance arrive en
troisième position avec 15 points 97 %
des voix ça a été tellement longue
tellement dure cette période entre les
six modes campagne lé mois de crise et
plus et dirt ce dernier mois avec une
fin de campagne absolument immonde
forcément je suis soulagé avec l' envie
de se mettre au travail rapidement
voilà avec cette nouvelle équipe à
plaisir avec 800 votes d'écart et 43
points 99 % des voix joséphine coleman
berger conserve son siège à la mairie et
pense déjà aux projets en cours pour la
ville face à elle patridge inter obtient
32 0 1% des voix
avec sa liste plaisir notre ville notre
avenir et annie joël prix ou hasseni
tête de liste de taff tout à faire pour
plaisir arrive en troisième position
avec 23 points 90
10% des voix des grands projets comme
les projets de la maison médicale qui va
démarrer incessamment sous peu on a
aussi tout le grand projet de l'éco
quartier du val hibou on a également
tout le projet du centre bourg ce sont
des projets que nous n'avons pas du tout
arrêter et qui sont vraiment dans cette
dynamique de la tente des plaisirs wa de
développer les espaces verts et d'être
dans cette dynamique là avec bien sûr
l'arrivée de tous liés assistance
médicale puisque nous avons trouvé des
médecins on est ravi les maires de ces
trois communes prendront place lors de
leur conseil d'installation le 3 juillet
pour plaisir et le 4 juillet pour
voisins le bretonneux et guyancourt
la zumba présent sur les résultats de ce
second tour des élections municipales
dans le reste du département que s'est
il passé à rambouillet carrières sous
poissy maisons laffitte le vésinet ou
encore lee mais la réponse de michael et
demi d'euros dans ce reportage
en dehors de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
des surprises des confirmations le
second tour des municipales 2020 a livré
son verdict dans les yvelines à
rambouillet véronique mathieu tête de
liste de rambouillet ensemble vers
l'avenir va succéder à marc robert elle
remporte l'élection avec 46 84 % des
suffrages remercie profondément les
rambolitains qui m'ont marqué leur
confiance
c'est vraiment un beau cadeau qu'ils me
font et j'espère être digne de en tous
les cas c'est comme ça que je ne
souhaite faire mon mandat est surtout
resté proche d'eux de son côté le
candidat écologiste david jutier termine
deuxième avec 37 0 6%
la déception la déception de ne pas
avoir gagné puisque c'était quand même
l'objectif numéro un
et puis on a un sentiment quand même de
devoir accompli vis-à-vis des électeurs
et électrices qui nous ont fait
confiance on a fait un score inédit à
rambouillet pour l'écologie politique
[Musique]
j'ai schmitt candidat investi par la
république en marche termine lui en
troisième position avec 16 10%
oui c'est un échec je le prends comme ça
personnellement je pense comme un échec
on n'a pas été capable je n'étais pas
dans la possibilité de tout cas pas
capable de fédérer les heat aura que qui
nous suit d'habitude et qui nous fait
confiance à carrières sous poissy ville
de 6000 habitants eddie aït maire de la
commune de 2008 à 2014 récupère son
fauteuil
l'homme politique à l'étiquette
écologiste a battu le maire sortant
divers droite christophe delrieu avec un
écart de 518 voix
khadija gamme raoui termine 3e avec 18
points 44% à maisons-laffitte jacques
myard élu depuis 1989 repartira pour un
sixième mandat dans la cité du cheval sa
liste lr arrive en tête dans 15 des 16
bureaux de vote et totalise 45 91% des
suffrages
yannick guin divers-droite termine
deuxième avec 37 84% à limay eric
rouleau est réélu maire avec 44,26 % des
suffrages le communiste devance la liste
divers droite de cécile dumoulin et la
liste divers-gauche du michael boutry
enfin vésinet le candidat lrm bruno
corps à des tiers et vend tête avec 32
points 54% des voix il devance la liste
et l'air de thibaut gripoix et les
listes divers droite de bernard grocaut
et françois bonneau
voilà pour ces résultats qui ont généré
forcément satisfaction mais aussi
déception notamment en raison de la
faible participation
on écoute à présent les réactions des
différents représentants des partis
politiques dans les yvelines qui se sont
exprimés hier dimanche lors de notre
soirée spéciale pour ces élections
municipales on a une formation qui
globalement tient le coup mais c'est
parce que aussi on a un man à un
maillage territorial qui est assez
proche du terrain qui est assez puissant
bien répartis dans le département des
yvelines est avec des maires surtout qui
font le travail et ça depuis plusieurs
mandats donc je crois qu'il ya une
reconnaissance aussi de la population
sur le travail qui est réalisé
murray joue est évidemment de la
victoire annoncée de jean baptiste à
monica à villepreux pour le modem après
la victoire de richard delpierre au
chesnay et celle de cédric pemba marina
à port-marly sont évidemment une de
jeunes mères une nouvelle génération et
je crois que c'est à cela que les que
les françaises et les français aspirent
j'ai souhaité bonne chance aux bandits
loi mais rien que la manière dont s'est
déroulé le scrutin au premier comme au
second tour avec des bureaux terme en
clairement tenu par des caïds
oui je trouve que la démocratie un père
d'une mairie où j'avais plus que le
rassemblement national
on peut appeler ça mitigé si vous voulez
moi je compte quand même beaucoup de
victoires
là où il y a encore six mois on avait
pas d'élu lit de mer étiqueté de jeu on
pourra toujours trouver des clauses pour
mitiger victoire il ya des défaites et
des victoires et des villes où ça un peu
déçu et les villes où ça extrêmement
content de voir la victoire de liste
menée par des marcheurs qui on a
parfaitement assumé leur étiquette est
pas une montre l'attraction mais les
événements jamais été malheureusement
beaucoup plus lointain une département
il y avait beaucoup de communes gérées
par la gauche
c'est loin d'être le cas depuis nantes
en mai
on a pas on a pas on n'a pas fait triste
figure qui voulaient globalement parce
qu'on a choisi d'y l'union et là où il a
eu des urbains malheureusement à la
verrière et l'a perdue à cause d'eux et
pourrait fermer cette édition spéciale
rappelons que pour ces élections
municipales ont voté également pour les
élus communautaires ceux qui siègent au
sein des intercommunalités à saint
quentin en yvelines sur les douze
communes de l'agglomération et 8 sont
désormais de sensibilité de droite ou de
centre droit les quatre autres conserve
une position à gauche
pas de changement profond donc des
équilibres politiques au sein du conseil
est la séance d'installation doit avoir
lieu le samedi 11 juillet au vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
quelles perspectives pour le prochain
mandat de six ans nicolas landry a posé
la question au président de
l'agglomération aux moyens techniques
patrick jacques de dixmude avec nous
jean michel fourgous président de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines bonjour bonjour alors avec vous
on va revenir sur ce second tour des
élections municipales 2020 à l'issue de
ce scrutin
cinq nouveaux maires ont été élus sur
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines à montigny le bretonneux
villepreux les clayes-sous-bois la
verrière et rap
comment allez-vous travailler avec eux
ces nouvelles personnes et vit d'abord
ça montre qu'un renouvellement naturel
en démocratie qui est plutôt une bonne
chose
alors globalement sur les douze communes
les messages que j'ai reçu de mes
collègues donc mer sont plutôt positifs
donc ya pas de grande inquiétude a
priori toute façon il ya il ya bien sûr
un noyau
centre-droit qui est majoritaire je
crois tout le monde s'en tient compte et
pour l'instant il n'y a pas de cas plus
tôt un climat de rassemblement d'énergie
de compétences d'expérience si bien sûr
mais au delà des étiquettes politiques
et c'est bien parce que c'est quand même
c'est un quant à céline agglomération
très économique qui va être confronté à
un choc économique homme d'une très
grande gravité fa le monde entier et la
france 50 ans comme tout le monde
donc voilà c'est bien que cette équipe
soit reste concentré sur sur ses
compétences lattes
alors avant de d'évoquer la communauté
d'agglomération revenons sur ce
basculement historique par votre famille
politique c'est la verrière et qui
bascule à droite alors basculement
également nationale puisque
hier soir on quand on faisait les
comptes devant d'abord effectivement la
tendance elle est en france est
majoritaire puisqu'elle a plus de 50 %
des mères et des équipes municipales
mans donc voilà bon alors chez nous
effectivement on gagne une ville de plus
donc
donc on est à a
donc là huit communes de droite pour
quatre communes de gauche sachant que
par exemple puis en cours c'est du
centre gauche modérée parce que c'est
une commune qui a une réalité économique
très forte avec des très belles
entreprises donc elle est confrontée aux
mêmes donc ça ça rend intelligent enfin
jure qu'il n'y a pas de dire qu' on n'a
pas de problème avec la culture de
l'équipe dirigeante de de guyancourt
là-dessus bon après voilà il ya il ya
deux autres petites communes qui sont
coignières et bien sûr et monsieur oui à
manille et puis il ya trappe
bon la trappe c'est le grand point
d'interrogation enfin voila mais non on
n'est pas inquiet en tout cas la
situation est quand même assez stabilisé
mais on est très content bien sûr
d'avoir enlevé ce dernier fief
communiste en plus c'est le communisme
vraiment une arrière garde
donc je pense que c'est un nouveau
souffle c'est un espoir pour la ville de
la verrière
nicolas david est un garçon brillant
travailleurs honnêtes cas des valeurs là
qui pointent des engagements qu'ils
respectent et voilà je dirais c'est
plutôt rassurant parce que la vérité du
travail pour la prochaine mandature
allez vous adopter la même position que
vous aviez pendant cette dernière
mandature c'est à dire donner une
vice-présidence à chaque maire de la
communauté d'agglomération et travailler
dans un état d'esprit trans partisan et
goûter pour l'instant est évident que la
majorité
les huit communes sur de droite du
centre droit bon là dessus on fait
passer des messages assez clairs et je
les connais un peu donc là dessus j'ai
pas d'inquiétude
après donc elles quatre autres communes
qui en fait à des reins mode
certains à des modes d'idéologique
compliqué j'avais je suis pas inquiet
mais parme
je ne suis pas inquiet de travailler
avec guyancourt c'est clair on l'a vu on
a déjà travaillé ensemble
vous voyez il ya neuf communes qui sont
quand même assez proche
voilà maintenant il faut voir je connais
moins monsieur fisher est nouveau mais
soyons est un peu plus éloigné
quant à
drap pour la série que des points
d'interrogation
je peux pas vous répondre à l' avance
avant de les voir avant mais globalement
aujourd'hui on a une large majorité de
toute façon pour faire tourner cette
cette agglomération mais c'est vrai que
mon objectif serait plutôt bien sûr
d'essayer de donner un maximum sinon à
tout le monde
bien entendu des délégations mais il
faut voir si ils sont dans cette crise
qui va être très forte s'ils sont bien
comme l intérieur alors on sait qu'on
respecte ici les idées chacun ya pas
prêt mais faut pas que quelqu'un rendent
pour pour dire je vais faire je vais
mettre en difficulté de l'intérieur la
wii non à ce moment là les gens ils
restent en dehors de l'exécutif mais
surtout avec la crise économique on n'a
pas les moyens d'aller jouer
voyez t de gauche qu'à droite et cités
ça voilà donc mais je pense que pour
l'instant il ya plutôt un rassemblement
de bonne volonté de tout le monde merci
jean michel fourgous président de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines et le conseil d'agglomération
d'installation aura lieu le samedi 11
juillet prochain au vélodrome nationale
fin de cette édition spéciale merci de
votre fidélité le replay est à consulter
sur notre site internet et notre
application mobile très belle soirée sur
tv 78
[Musique]